poor daily save and fair those are the
key words in a proposal for a new
European Asylum system presented by the
EU Commission today let's be clear
migration will be one of the main
challenges the European Union has to
face together in the longer term this
issue is not going away so Europe will
need sustainable future proof migration
policies that provide orderly and safe
pathways to the EU the existing
so-called Dublin rules on migration have
been criticised there many as obsolete
and unfair to countries like Greece and
Italy the proposed reforms suggest two
options option one keeps the current
system in place but would give countries
under particular pressure the
possibility to call for help the
fairness mechanism would then allow them
to resettle migrants within the EU a
second more drastic option would scrap
the Dublin rules a European agency could
then in the long run distribute asylum
seekers according to a permanent quota
but members of the European Parliament
are already criticizing this approach
that is for entirely Cafaro PA
news and I'd find the creation of this
kind of institution at a European level
bizarre of course we need to think about
why the same categories of people are
more likely to be granted asylum in some
states than in others but the solution
cannot involve centralizing these tasks
we need better coordination boozy
peasant redundant upstream the proposed
reform presents fundamental change to
how the EU deals with asylum seekers but
including a permanent distribution
scheme for migrants has always been
fiercely opposed by Central and Eastern
European countries and there are no
signs that their position is going to
change anytime soon